- Les clés sont là.
- Pour la premiè
Tiana s'apprête à faire
le trajet Longueui
dans un véhicule loué auprès
d'un particulier.
- J'ai fait beaucoup de ride
share, AirBnb, je m'y connais
aussi. Fait que, je suis comme,
je fais confiance aux autres,
et ça er dans ce marché-là.
- L'application Turo fonctionnee
la location de voiture,
- Pour les assurances.
d'assurances similaire à celle
teurs de véhicules
traditionnels.
- Je ne trouve pasdetails.
- La journée avait pourtant
commencé avec des difficultés
techniques, qui se sont; le jeun
vaut la chandelle.
- La dernière fois, j'ai pris
une Communauto, puis ça revient
je pense que, oui, finalement,
est l'option la moins
chère, et à date, ça a l'air
d'être
- Turo est en plein essor par
rapport à l'été dernier.
Les réservations ont bondi de
188 % à Montréal, de 194 % às dà
l'échelle canadienne.
CÉDRIC MATHIEU, V.-P. en charge
du Canada pour Turo
- Il y a un environnement
la location entre particuliers,
'autopartage entre
particuliers, du fait de
la pénur
location à travers le pays.
- Les ende location
ayant vendu une partie de leurs
voitures en début elles peinentà
renouveler leur parc automobile.
- On est très confiants sur
le fait que les gens qui vonr T,
continueront de l'utiliser.
- Mais la fiabilité n'est pas
toujours au rendez-vous.t actife
Communauto, Joakim fait
le saut vers Turo pour
les vacances au chalet et
économiser quelques dollars.
JOAKIM LEMIEUX, utilisatrice de
l'application Turo- Là, on s'esr
cette secette secette secette sr
pour dire que, bien, notre
réservation était nne qui nous .
- Les annulations exaspèrent de
nombreux clients. Les jeunes
parents ont néanmoins choisi de
donner ul'applicl'applicl'appli.
FRÉDÉRIC DUCHESNE, client Turo
- C'est sûr qu'on "flip"
un 25 cent. Soit on y va avec
2-3000$ pour une location,
soit on y va avec un marché
foisonnant avec ses infiabilités
comme ça.
- Les prochaines s
révèleront si le pari est
réussi...
- ... comme pour Tiana qui
tiliser Turo à l'avenir.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
C'est le début de